when you first learn about the
Constitutional Convention in 1787 and
the debates and the compromises it's
easy to assume that okay that's
interesting from a historical point of
view but how does it affect me today
well the simple answer is it affects you
incredibly those compromises that were
made over 200 years ago so the most
obvious question is well what were those
compromises well to even start to
appreciate the compromises let's start
with this picture or this chart of the
census in 1790 so it gives a pretty good
snapshot of what the United States
looked like after the Constitution was
ratified so as you can see the
population as a whole was much smaller
than it is today it was roughly a little
under 4 million people today the United
States is over 300 million people and
then you also see a pretty big
population difference between the states
you have big states like Virginia which
at the time had 750,000 people and then
you had small states like Delaware that
had 60,000 people or you have Rhode
Island that has a little under 70,000
people and so you could imagine the
Virginians or the people from
Massachusetts might've said hey we want
representation in the legislative in
Congress to be based on population it
should be you know we have a lot of
people we should get more of a say while
someone from say Delaware might say wait
hold on a second under the Articles of
Confederation we were a sovereign state
we don't want to just become you know do
whatever the Virginians or the people
from Massachusetts want to do we want to
have a more equal say and of course the
big state folks would have said well no
then your population people in your
population in your state are going to be
over-represented and so this was a
serious debate and it resulted in what
is called the great compromise the great
compromise which is probably the most
cited compromise coming out of the US
Constitution and it's the notion of okay
well let's have it both ways
in the legislative let's create two
houses let's do one house that is based
on population so the House of
Representatives wherever Virginia will
get more representation than a Delaware
but then let's make another house called
the Senate where every state has equal
representation where you have two
senators per state and to appreciate
that this is all even today a
controversial thing here is an article
from the New York Times from 2013 this
is an article that's talking about
perceived inequalities of per person
federal funding and it says and the
article is literally named big state
small state
Vermont's six hundred twenty five
thousand residents have two United
States senators and so two New York's 19
million that means that a Vermonter has
30 times the voting power in the Senate
of a New Yorker just over the state line
the biggest inequality between two
adjacent states the nation's largest gap
between Wyoming and California is more
than double that so they're making the
argument that at least in the Senate a
person in Vermont has 30 times the
representation as a person in New York
and if you compare Wyoming in California
it's a factor of 60 and they say the
difference reflects the growing
disparity in their citizens voting power
and it is not an anomaly the
Constitution has always given residents
of states with small populations a lift
so this is coming straight out of the
Great Compromise but the size and
importance of the gap has grown markedly
in recent decades in ways the framers
probably never anticipated so you can
imagine this is the New York Times so
they probably might favor a little bit
more representation for New Yorkers but
it's an interesting thing to think about
the Constitution was written over 200
years ago
could they have predicted how much the
United States would grow be the movement
to the cities even in that census of
1790 we saw a factor of a little more
than 10 between a Virginia and say Rhode
Island but now we're talking about a
factor of 60 between California and
Wyoming there's no right answer here but
it is something very interesting to
think about and as you can see it's
something that people are even talking
about today now the other significant
compromise that is also talked a lot
about these days is the enocean of the
electoral college so people who are more
in the anti-federalist camp they were
more in favor of a participatory
democracy a direct democracy where you
have one person one vote and whoever
gets the majority of the vote in the
country well maybe they should be
President
but Federalists especially folks like
James Madison they were a little
suspicious of just the crowd voting
whoever they wanted they wanted it to go
through a filter with the idea that
maybe that filter could temper the the
passions of the crowd so to speak and so
they devised this system where it isn't
one person one vote but every state has
a certain number of electors so you vote
for electors and then the states send
them and then they can place their vote
for president it turns out that most
states have decided to have a
winner-take-all policy so that maybe
they could matter more for the
presidential election but what that's
resulted in is if you take a big state
like Texas and draw quick drawing of
Texas or a big state like California
right over here and a winner-take-all as
soon as you cross 50% you get fifty
point one percent and either either one
of these states and in other big states
is true in most states well then you'll
get all the electors for that state so
even if you get 70 percent of the vote
in Texas or 70 percent in the vote of
California its equivalent to getting
50.1%
the reason why this has resulted in some
significant debate in in the recent past
you've had two major elections where the
electoral college majority was different
than the popular majority you had Bush
versus Gore in 2000 and you have Trump
versus Clinton in 2016 now two of the
other major compromises that came out of
the Constitutional Convention are less
debated today and that's a good thing
because they were resolved finally in
1865 by the 13th amendment that came out
of the Civil War
and these were around slavery you have
the three-fifths three-fifths compromise
and this is actually still more of a
notion around representation even in the
house how do you determine the
population that's going to dictate how
many representatives you get what about
slaves if you look back to this chart
right over here notice some of the
southern states had a significant
fraction of their population that were
slaves and so you could imagine that
their delegates were saying hey we want
to count them in the population they
didn't want to count they didn't want
them to vote but they said hey when we
decide how many representatives we get
we want to count these 293,000 people in
Virginia when we decide how many
representatives they get and you can
in other states either just because they
didn't want to dilute their own
representation or maybe even some of
them might have felt morally against
something like slavery said wait no we
you shouldn't get a benefit because
you're doing this thing called slavery
and so they were against it and so the
compromise and once again James Madison
was significantly involved here was a
three-fifths compromise that for
determining representation a slave would
count as three-fifths of a person which
is offensive to our sensibilities but
that's the compromise they came up with
but it didn't because it wasn't an issue
anymore once the slavery was abolished
by the Thirteenth Amendment
the last major compromise that people
will talk about and this one also
revolves around slavery is the
importation importation of slaves during
the revolution because Great Britain had
such a significant role in the slave
trade the the colonies were pretty you
or the states the nascent states were
pretty unified around not participating
at least with Great Britain but once the
revolution was over this became an issue
again some states did not want more
importation of slaves some did and so
the compromise that was reached is that
at least for 20 years the Congress would
not pass a law that is prohibiting the
importation of slaves and it turns out
almost exactly 20 years later once that
expired from the Constitution under
Thomas Jefferson they did ban the
importation of slaves officially
although it still continued to some
degree at a much smaller level I'll
leave you there but the big appreciation
here is that those debates that we
talked about the great compromise the
electoral college these debates around
representation that we saw over 200
years ago these are things that people
still feel passionate about and they
still debate today